how uh have you been in uh corn team man
how you been holding up yeah i've been
thriving brother
how sorry i mean dude like okay there's
there's [ __ ] that sucks about it and and
and there's [ __ ] that rules like what
sucks is
we had started filming jackass four
right like a fourth movie which
i agree it makes no [ __ ] sense i'm
all for it
i mean actually like we got one week
into filming jackass four
and uh that's when the shutdown happened
yeah which is
a pisser it's also a blessing because
there are obvious question marks around
whether a bunch of [ __ ] 40 and in
some cases
50 you know john is knoxville 50
yeah i will be soon i think he's 49 yeah
he's up there a couple of the other guys
have crossed
50.
i'm so for him i know i'm all about it
right knoxville believes firmly that the
older you get the funnier
it is i agree i don't know 100 i think
at a certain point it just gets kind of
uh tough to watch but
but hey man i i don't mind a bit and and
the one week that we were able to film
uh the chemistry was there the [ __ ]
footage everything's worked out
fantastically so
we were able to put together enough
footage in that one week
for the question marks to be answered
yeah where can we still do it
yeah can we see the chemistry still
there is it gonna be fun does it still
work
whose idea was it to get back together
i'm sure knoxville
everybody else has just been clamoring
for it my position was like hey man i
never stopped doing that [ __ ] anyway so
yeah it's [ __ ] like
a movie or no movie i'm i'm active you
know like that's what i was gonna say
out of the group of guys you're the one
guy who just kind of
i mean you're just doing the damn i just
did it the other guy's kind of maybe
because i don't follow it as close
because you and i are boys but i see
what you're doing you're kind of the one
guy
who's just kind of doing it i've stayed
out there yeah i'm super active
i've stayed active so i was cool either
way um but
yeah it was what we did in the one week
it went very well paramount pictures a
as i understand it is just thrilled with
uh
with the whole idea of it now so we
became a bigger priority on their radar
for when the world does begin to spin
again
yeah it definitely stopped from getting
really yeah no [ __ ]
now dude do i'm assuming they go
and if this is too much tell me steve do
they go through your agent to figure out
payment wise you know what i'm saying
because like now the terms are a little
different
like you were a big star yeah you know
what i'm saying
you're totally fine to ask and thanks
for for flagging
you know the the sensitivity um
i did it's so funny man i in all the
years
leading up to i never even [ __ ]
countered
an offer i just found out what i was
gonna get and i was like cool
because the reason i bring it up is
because i was telling somebody at some
random fan at starbucks he's like oh who
do you have on today
and i was like oh stevo and he goes oh
he got did you hear him he got [ __ ]
on the other movies and i was like no
man no i didn't i didn't know that
it was uh did we started out
like a big bad you know what he was
talking about
was the first season of the tv show
jackets
and uh for that i mean dude that's entry
level you gotta pay you knew how well it
would go
right a hundred percent we'd gone from
making skateboard videos to now we're
on mtv like we didn't get paid for the
skateboard videos
and you know so they were like okay for
this first season we're gonna pay you
like per bit you know each thing that
you shoot and if the thing that you're
shooting
is uh really dangerous and you can get
like
you know hurt then we're gonna pay you
500 bucks for that bit
if it's just like a funny prank or some
kind of a gag
you know then uh 200 bucks
sounds good like or just give us a flat
fee man you would think that per episode
would be the the ticket but it was all
just like such a just a hodgepodge
yeah it sounds complicated is it because
they didn't know like how big it would
get
yeah they didn't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing so um they didn't know how
many guys were gonna be a part of it you
know
like there were like a bunch of
different characters in the skateboard
videos that sort of turned into jackass
they weren't even clear on who was going
to be uh the cast
you know they just sort of has i think
that's what what motivated that
but at the end of the day uh after taxes
i made
less than fifteen hundred bucks for the
first season
no residuals no not there why not you
know and then the other guys make
way more like did john the captain on
the ship right for sure
yeah he got like you know he's smart
dude all the the the producer [ __ ] the
residual [ __ ] the ownership of the
the creator [ __ ] you know like johnny's
a smart guy yeah and uh
yeah yeah he's like
a
come on
yeah so uh yeah i mean even whatever
like
from the project after that um
it it got better it got better you know
but now this time around
and like i said i mean i i had agents in
the past but the agents were like oh
okay this is what you're going to get
and i was like
okay cool yeah this time around it's
like oh okay
well guys i need to speak up for myself
at this point because for the last 10
it's been 10 [ __ ] years
since the last movie and so over the
last 10 years
like i've stayed active you know
yeah without like being a dick you know
like
i'm the only guy that [ __ ] has been
active you know like i've been
been building momentum i've been doing
my thing i think that it's safe to say
that at this point i bring more to the
table
than the rest of the guys that's where i
was going without being offensive yeah
yeah and and
i don't think that that's uh a [ __ ]
thing to say it was like it was an
observation and and then
what's more important for me is that i
i didn't want to like get in there and
be
the one like fighting for i was like hey
you know what like
the last time around i had my lawyer
telling me yo
we've got a counter and i was like no
the lawyer's like why do you have this
right and uh you know because the the
last time around i was newly sober
like i didn't know if i had it in me
yeah you know i was just like this was
for the movie
but for jen you were sober when you did
the slingshot
yeah in the porter party porta potty
slingshot i was completely sober
let me ask you a question do you ever
like do a stunt and you when you're
about to do it you're like
no it's just [ __ ] ah
fake them out like man it's called it's
called jackass it's not dumb
especially now that you're sober you
know i feel like yeah
yeah i mean like in hindsight i i really
went on to regret
uh not letting my lawyer like fight you
know and so this time i just said hey
guys i think
i bring more to the table this time
around and this time i'm going to stay
out of my own way
and i'm going to do what my lawyer let
them do
i'm going to let my guy do what he does
you know and
uh so i extricated myself from the
the you know the situation and my lawyer
did say this is [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know
and and we and and then we uh kind of
got into the
the standoff sort of so to speak you
know and um
it was just really something else man
i'd never really gone down that path
you know of where to find like how
contentious you know how like it's sort
of
you know it's like wow like
you know it's like wow man like like
when you're fighting over money like
because we're not negotiating with uh
the parent with the movie studio
you know already the production
companies give you a budget the
production company which is knoxville
and spike jones and jeff tremaine like
they've they've got their deal with the
with the studio yeah
paramount pictures and so now there it's
up to them to
deal with us so anything that we get
comes out of their [ __ ]
and so that's what i came to learn is
like wow they're really [ __ ] pretty
they're pretty serious about digging in
their heels and and uh
getting real [ __ ] heavy over this and
um
the good thing is you know they can't do
it without like
hey there's a new jackass but there's no
steve i'm like
i'm not going it got to it got to a
point where
where my lawyer even was like wow you
know like
we got like you know we got a little
better
and you know at this point i just can't
tell i can't advise you to pass on this
you know
and so i was like hey guys it's all i
needed was my guy
to say the word go and so yeah i don't
think that i got anything really
like uh uh substantial in the way of
like
i think it's a respect thing yeah it's
almost yeah you know what i'm saying
and whatever it was overall it was a
wildly uncomfortable process
you know like and and it is kind of
heartbreaking when it's like
when you're when you're bros but you
know i just come to learn that's the
nature of the world
[ __ ] it you know and show business right
yeah as soon as the deal was done and we
showed up for that
that one week of filming if i could all
forgotten that we're laughing our asses
off the chemistry's there
the footage is great do you guys still
see each other outside of this like do
you communicate
sure is the band still yeah for sure
we've always been
we've always been cool we don't like
hang out all the time you know and it's
kind of like if something's really funny
like oh man like we'll i'll
send this over that you know but uh you
know
it's uh we're we're bros we're all we're
all a family and there's
there's no hard feelings about anything
and like
honestly because i uh
have been so active like i stand to
benefit
so much more from the film than anybody
else
because you're on the road your podcast
right i've got
i've got established revenue streams
that are going to be [ __ ]
supercharged by this so like this is if
i viewed the movie as just an
engine that's going to drive my other
evidence
so it really was kind of a matter of
principle it was a matter of respect
my guy said go for it it's great plus
they got me a
producer credit which is kind of cool
there's a lot that's pretty [ __ ] cool
who comes up with the ideas
how we do because you guys have come up
with so much [ __ ] right you know what
i'm saying like
at some point it's like what else we
gonna do when i get off stage at the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song